dr samarantani speaks over video of
himself in profile view i went to school
for computer engineering in india dr
anthony speaks to viewer samir antani
phd tenure track investigator
computational health research branch
lhcbc i've worked with image processing
computer vision pattern recognition
machine learning
so my world was filled with
developing algorithms that could extract
interesting objects from
images and videos animated circles and
lines overlay close-up of a woman's eye
text pattern recognition appears above
her eye pattern recognition is a family
of techniques that looks for particular
pixel characteristics or voxel
characteristics inside an image and
learns to recognize those objects
animated model of a brain between two
tall cabinets of computer networking
equipment text deep learning deep
learning is a way of capturing the
knowledge inside an image and
encapsulating it dr antani working at
his laptop and then researchers like me
spend time advancing newer deep learning
networks that look more
broadly into an image radiologic and
rendered views of human skull images
organ tissue images of cellular
biological material recognizing these
objects recognizing organs in my case
and diseases and converting those
visuals into numerical risk predictors
that could be used by clinicians so my
research is currently in three very
different areas one area looks at
cervical cancer text cervical cancer
appears over video of purple cells a
machine could look at the images and be
a very solid predictor of the risk to
the woman of developing cervical
pre-cancer encouraging early treatment
text sickle cell disease appears over
video of red cells another area i work
with a sickle cell disease one of the
risk factors in sickle cell disease is
cardiac myopathy or cardiac muscle
disease which leads to stroke and or
perhaps even death nurse smiles at
patient reclined in a hospital bed
cardiac echo videos looking at cardiac
echo videos and using ai to be a solid
predictor along with other blood lab
tests automated lab equipment moves lab
vials improves the chances of survival a
third area of that i'm interested in is
understanding the expression of
tuberculosis text tuberculosis appears
over video of blue cells in just x-rays
panel images of chest x-rays
particularly for children and those that
are hiv positive the expression of
disease in that sub-population is very
different from adults with tb who are
not hiv positive two men with their arms
over each other every clinician have
seen a certain number of patients in
their clinical training a montage of
working physicians they perhaps have
spent more time at hospitals or clinical
centers and exposed to certain
population and they become very adept at
that population machines on the other
hand could be trained on data that is
free of bias a diverse group of smiling
people from different parts of the world
different ethnicities different age
groups so that there's an improved care
giving and therefore a better
expectation on treatment and care on a
white background grain blue nlm logo
appears above grey text serving
scientists and society